what's up y'all welcome to the cauce
that's three times you beat me what do
you do uess mad at me I didn't know
she's better than you in every way I
would kick you over her like look at her
but it's like all these guys like who
don't want to hug up on gwyn for two
second I have boobs also I've got a dad
maybe bigger
oh I hope that gets on the TV well you
know the day I made myself a peanut
butter jelly sandwich right I'll buy
yourself had it on this really tasty hot
bread is it Wyatt
or is it wait I can't tell the day why
is it Wyatt freighter boyfriend that bit
[Music]
what is a matter with you what is him
he'll say he'll see she loves me what a
good man I'm just happy then screwed up
he's such a good man bleh look it's look
at hey come back what are you doing
you're like the Sasquatch you're like
Bigfoot lost in the woods man you look
like Chewbacca right now
it's tradition
what about like a proposal on the show
what do you think would that make you
feel weird
that would be my dream come true can I
teach anyone my dances and just be an
idiot I tried to do that one I couldn't
couldn't do it maybe have you tried it
out I think Alicia can do it everyone
with them ready it's hard as a lot of
things at one time you get too many
phrases the word
[Music]